Tiffany is in Atlanta Georgia hi Tiffany
how are you I'm well and yourself better
than I deserve what's up in your world a
lot first off just to get straight to
the point my husband and I we make about
$65,000 after tax and we have
approximately $300,000 in students and
in debt including more than half of that
is student loans I would say about two
hundred seventy five thousand that
student loan actually more more than
that who's the doctor or lawyer where is
a doctor lawyer no are you and I'm sorry
we're we are we just have bachelor's
degree this is not for any advanced
degrees you got bachelor's degrees for
$275,000 yes on my end but the portion
of it that's my loan is a hundred and
fifty upwards of $150,000 and your
degrees in what mine isn't economics his
is in sociology with a minor in
criminology but he's working in retail
management now so yeah it's not anywhere
related but I'm working as an irony here
that's unbelievable you have a degree in
economics yeah and you borrowed a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars to
get that degree that irony doesn't
escape me does it you it doesn't escape
me either the only I'm this is not an
excuse but the only thing I can say is
that one of your financial guru
colleagues if you will at the time when
I was going into college this individual
was saying that student loans that is
good that it wasn't I don't know you
can't lump that person anywhere in the
same sentence with me you're right
because I would not be one of there
would not be anyone I would have
anything to do with so anyway aside from
that you now have an economics degree
and have discovered that advice to be
not true so now what are we going to
what are you going to do because your
careers are both stalling aren't they um
they're not progressing at the level
that we needed to be in order for us to
continue to pay off and do our baby
steps properly and that is my primary
question the the loan that the largest
is with Sallie Mae
and that my loan it's a hundred and
fifty seven thousand dollars the highest
interest rate on one of the loans is
fourteen point something percent
I think fourteen point six percent and
Allie Mae it was telling me yes sir
and with a cosigner um nevertheless at
this point in time they would like to
reduce my rate to two percent great
which was bring my monthly payment down
from thirteen hundred dollars a month to
six hundred dollars a month however as
you may be able to kind of deduce this
Sallie Mae loan is not our first the
first in our baby steps this would be
one of our last baby steps so my husband
is of the mentality that first of all we
should pay off those smaller loans so
that we will have more to pay Sallie Mae
later I'm sorry you just said they're
going to reduce your interest rate why
do you have to put it up in the baby
steps to accept the reduced interest
rate um well from what I thought and I'm
sure you're correct me as long I thought
that baby steps meant that based on our
income we need to pay off the loans that
we can pay and the baby step number two
is the debt snowball in the way we teach
that one is we say list your debts
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything except the smallest one
and attack the smallest debt with a
vengeance reducing the interest rate on
any of those does not harm that equation
at all okay and that would be very
helpful as a matter of fact so here's
your here's their math issue that's
scaring me for you guys and I decide
you've got to work on yes take that 2%
deal for sure because it doesn't change
anything except lower a payment you
lower the payment gives you more money
to attack the others you'll get back to
this loan when you get down to it and
the baby steps but you got to get your
income up your ratio of income to debt
is driving me nuts here it's scary your
shovel - the size of the hole you're in
is out of whack we got to get your
income up way up
you
you